[Music]
and careful what you tweet news never
situation you know even if you delete
your tweets anybody can access it anyone
submitted by its me a girl hello
a realism scandal is currently tearing
apart the YouTube beauty guru scene not
the beauty guru scene like Jen MC the N
word away oh so sweet there's like too
many beauty gurus now right there's a
million I have a [ __ ] beauty guru
dude everybody's it
I am beauty guru we do go to beauty
Klein does that count
yep that man really invite beautycon
[ __ ] I was born in the wrong generation
I would have gone I was schooled all you
[ __ ] I would love to see that we've
seen you with makeup on you're just
Ursula exactly and I looked amazing you
did you were fire he the wedding the
matchmaker in the one no oh okay so this
whole drama here no I'm making a bigger
table it looked like you're trying to
reset your computer no I'm making I was
trying to buy you time
thank you I was trying to make these
photos bigger so I could show you this
whole drop okay so you guys know Shane
Dawson has been doing this documentary
yeah yeah
so recently he did one on Geoffrey start
I heard that was really good i watch it
though i actually so he did a five part
series on Jeffrey star
I only saw the first one it's not
another breast but out of that it this
whole drama surfaced aware snip so he he
was just saying how all these people
around him I he helped bring them up but
then that he ended up being the bad guy
and then he's always been kind of seen
as a racist like a lot of people
accusing them being a racist so Gabriel
Zamora another beauty guru he posted
this photo with Laura Lee Nikita dragon
and many MUA which they're all I thought
you're gonna say manny pacquiao that
would have better don't mass combination
i don't know any of those people you
just name yeah let me just are you in on
the drama I know about I know about this
because Jess was all upon that
documentary and I was like I saw the
tonic on [ __ ] and bashing oh so I was
like let me wait until all of these are
done and I'm a binge watch it now
they're all out you watch this [ __ ]
dragongirl better be Asian the photo
that sparked a lot of [ __ ] so it's the
four of them having the real fingers up
saying [ __ ] is better because without
him we're doing better
who Gabriel tweeted this to the Jeffery
did know in his own [ __ ] is referring
to Jeffery I'm tweeting I guess that's
what the kids call it these days so then
more about so then the next one so ever
this could have been Vegas [ __ ] right
but then he solidified who he was
talking to with his next tweet which is
imagine standing a racist
I could never what is standing standing
you know Eminem some stuff in like super
fan could you do a rap for you you can't
wrap it I'm not Nick is that the
remember me my girlfriend's preggers and
I'm gonna kill myself I was busy I
couldn't write back but here I am Oh too
late I saw some guys ya know sounds
pretty good is that crazy oh [ __ ] wait
those you letter yeah that was the first
track I ever listened to with raindrops
and it sounded very nice
alright kiddo
ditto Dido
these things don't matter yes it does so
this is Gabriel could've been here -
it'd be just the same how a song from
our era is now a word [ __ ] things for
the kids today standing they just took
our [ __ ] and made it their [ __ ] I like
it all right so this is Gabriel I don't
understand Inc he's the one that sweeted
that photo and the next week here's a
clean finger this is Manny whoa look at
that beard so he's in the photo
this is Nikita dragon she's trans yeah
she's Trent she's she's like look so
good she's so hot that's why a Asians
make the best trans I like her hair
color where which way is she going Oh
guide a girl okay so yes she's and then
this is Laura Lee so these are the four
people involved is she is she I can't I
can't tell now do it that's amazing seen
the beauty pageant trans beauty pageant
in Thailand my friend took pictures with
all the beauty queens and I was like
damn they finer than the than the real
ladies yeah you look really good Billie
Jo
yeah they look really good yeah anyway
moving on oh great this whole dynamic is
great all right so games we're noticing
you do a great job you know just your
mom's good I am a mom actually have a
thin your own self [ __ ] whatever old
years yeah exactly
girls you can't even tell her she don't
got no belly I do means you pregnant why
would you have a belly yeah belly
because does you have a bell
Polly she had a baby recently let me see
do you I don't know do I know you don't
know got a belly either all right let me
keep telling you this drama because it
is okay yeah I want to know it's juicy
Gabriel the next week he says is a honey
every time I was around him talking
about Jeffrey he would constantly say
racist things about black people but I
would validate but would validate it by
saying I've had so much black dick I
couldn't be racist to use racial slurs
and I think that a person of the color
is less than you so he's further saying
that Jeffrey is racist but then people
did but he had so much black dick that
makes it okay yeah is a new racist that
doesn't mean you're treating that person
as a prop for your sexual needs yeah
exactly
black means not just their dicks yeah
everything how could you obviously be
racist if you love sucking black dick
alright so then people do their
sleuthing and they found or what
sleuthing again a detective sniffing
around got it they will be just be using
words now words words words skin all
right people just be using words so they
found this tweets of Gabriel where he
used the n-word
oh no he's like n-word had nothing
better to do than take a H or er I don't
know it's blurred out
well that's very important and it's
either original it's 2012 yes this is
back in 2012 it's blinking so this is
his caption to an Instagram post and
then people found that and then he says
well we love receipts without context so
let me lend a hand this was in 2012 and
that's when I learned why that word was
it for me to use my friends explained it
to me and I've respected ever since
there's there should be a statue of
limitations for that word so that was
for Gabriel right then every other
person in that photo except for Manny
for some reason Manny doesn't have any
dirt that people have dug up but oh wait
before I finish a Gabriel he did tweet
I'm sorry Jeffrey sorry trust me it's
been
i opening 24 hours like he went back on
when he was saying so that was Gabriel
nothing's happening with Manny Nikita
dragon they've dug this up saying I want
her tweet says I'm not saying your child
is ugly I'm saying you will never have
to worry about pedophile thanks that's
why whose child is she talking about
just a child
this next one is we've all met a child
sorry that's a really funny way to say
your kids ugly yeah even a pedophile one
want to touch your kid yeah that's
pretty do you get insulted you're like
that was a good but how do you as a
brand I would you get mad at that like
how dare you say a pedophile wouldn't
shot touching my child
Yeah right my child's not beautiful
enough to be touched my kid what a child
take that back here I just thought play
so my job will be molested start beating
your mom on Twitter how dare you
well happy such a funny five feet that's
such a great
you started kicking that person's ass
your child will be ready yes that's
right many so many men want to touch my
house binary trans spoke as well that's
why didn't get it what's wrong with that
specific tweet it's funny I honestly
didn't tell you it's really it's it's
Twitter you can't make jokes on Twitter
oh it seems like in the the social
whatever the climate of this generation
if you put kids and pedophile in the
same sentence then you're in trouble
yeah that's what it seems Oh everybody's
getting here dough like Sarah Silverman
had a sketch with patent pending on Walt
about like yes pedophiles and yeah he's
getting it out Michael Ian Black skin
there now like every tip the ones that
make jokes about it they're all getting
like jokes were way harder like twenty
two thousand five one like yeah those
have like jokes like a rule everyone
like was like joking but you know I mean
like your problem if you view Sarah
Silverman as a gangster like there's a
comedian you think her
Ranchi than like man we are very
watching this yeah do you halogens right
I mean they they do it I don't think you
have to do it I don't think you should
though butts like how can you be you
yeah well because it's it's I think if
they're just like that's the person like
you should know better but it's like how
would I know that the future or [ __ ]
was gonna be deleted right dupage but
now that we made jokes here today oh it
happened in 20 years are gonna dig up
you have to go and apologize below we're
not gonna do group apologies we're gonna
do group [ __ ] yous we're gonna go on
stage and we're like I I prepared a
speech and I just want I just want the
world to know [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah that's what the speech is about by
the way please follow me because like
every celebrity comes out and they
apologize but none of them will just say
you know what that was [ __ ] five years
ago it was it was a different time then
and if everybody said that wouldn't be a
problem I would I think everybody should
say should say that because it's like my
intention was never to hurt does it make
people laugh or like you can't in order
to my excuse my theory in order to get
past a painful thing a lot of comedians
what they do is they tackle the pain
through comedy because it flips it and
you and you and you're like oh okay like
I can do like in my case people like
well you said this and I was like my
intention was to hurt and it worked at
the time everyone is acceptable I don't
know but my intention was to hurt you
and it worked
so enjoy fact is go about my day it
doesn't [ __ ] matter man [ __ ] you yeah
so back to this drama because there's
still a couple more people are gonna
cover so this is another one her tweets
Nikita dragons tips we've all met a
child that makes us realize child abuse
began for a reason why that's me like if
I had a kid like like I don't even blame
I must be in my ass ugly
I mean word oh like kids of immigrants
right I'll for sure we got beat I've
gotten abused as a child
yes sir this is a spanking weapon yeah
Beck's yeah I deserved it so like she
kind of just like a little big fan of
gawky for this but the person that's
gotten the most heat is Laura Lee so she
actually has wait wait wait what is that
you buy for the Chinese like a 1980s job
folder Chinese person put sauce over
there I think it's the hash tag gum gum
goop yeah yeah saying dumb n-word I
didn't see that part another so they're
saying that some of these might not be
real because she deleted all her tweets
but I thought we could bring him back up
I don't know that's a comedy crime for
not being funny but dumb boobies a [ __ ]
you go but that's also not being funny
that's a comedy crime n words in Paris
what I thought they couldn't afford to
leave Compton lol the next little
problem those jokes aren't even like
funny there aren't even job if but if
somebody tells me a racist joke you know
about any people or like about me and if
it's funny I'm lazy you could appreciate
it I can appreciate I can't tell effort
and there's and you understood the pulse
of my community in the context of that's
just an insult this is just like oh that
is racist oh yeah being racist I'm just
like that's not funny yes I know fun I'm
mad that it's not it didn't make me
laugh like so bad sunny good luck yeah
so if like him I have one role on my
Instagram Twitter anything you could try
to clown on me as much you want it has
to but it has to be funny you know how
you know how secure you have to be with
yourself for somebody to insult you to
be like that's it's too much time but
somebody wrote something on my it's like
true woken us yeah [ __ ] it roasted to
not to not be affected by like you know
Joe somebody wrote my Instagram and I
read it and I started cracking the [ __ ]
up I just wrote lol to the I did but
then it was another one they were like
oh Kim Jong is so bad it's there's no
effort there's not to be block bro
it's just want to hear the rest that I
want to hear the one that she's been
saving yes the one that I've been saving
the one that she's being in the most
heat for the one that is
it is confirmed that she tweeted this is
tip for all black people if you pull
your pants up you can run from the
police faster hashtag you're welcome
that's kind of did that too so and she
retweeted some other [ __ ] that she
retweeted but it was pretty bad so she
ended up posting so she was silent for a
week she didn't say anything
dropping subscribers like crazy she I
think what is that the worst week well I
mean there are other ones but we don't
know if they're for sure hurts other the
dumb closes against does that one I'm
trying to figure out is it funny that
was just like a pull your pants up yeah
yeah but that one I can tell you that it
is confirmed for sure the first two that
I showed you it or was it that people
are getting mad what I like you're
calling black people slow we're actually
really fast you know what this seems
like this seems like everybody's just
like Petty and and jealous or at each
other and they're using these as like
weapons to each other down it's like
there's no I'm sure your intention is
not to solve racism into you know I mean
I'm pretty sure you are like have some
personal drama yeah and it's like how do
I tear this place apart cuz what's the
what's the hot thing you know I mean
there's a lot of you let are right I'm
sure the intention behind this does not
seem like it's like you know what like
as I'm trying to be a voice for the
community it's just like it's like I
feel like all these they just have
personal drama yeah and when people have
personal drama they'll you still go to
whatever except to make you look bad and
what's the hottest weapons of choice
right now yeah it's like racism and and
like just just this stuff like whatever
is like the most triggering for the
Twitter community it's like let me use
those yeah and you can so that's what
they seems like it's like a 10 percent I
don't I don't
okay I don't yeah I don't care / I don't
believe your intention is what what
happened not about what if if I got
called a racist and I returned back as
I'm hundred percent yes I am because
this world but you would get report
Brown or something she's that she's the
girl from Alabama I don't know I've done
it before because you know how everyone
says how come you guys don't invite Josh
how come you like they're kind of like
saying is it because he's black or
whatever so then in one of my comments
this guy was like how come you didn't
invite Josh I just said cuz he's black
even though we have another black person
in a picture
you're just clearly a joke though
there's like so much context in that
picture alone I know he does yeah Laura
she like I said she's been getting most
of the cheapo heat she did she posted
this Apollo I was gonna show you guys
but it's fine you don't need to see it
she's posted like this this video of her
just sobbing everyone saying it's hella
fake that she's like suit like her voice
is super high-pitched and even Jeffrey
commented on like she this is her worst
acting ever I've seen her cry in real
life it's nothing like this oh I think
he deleted that tweet and then so all
this [ __ ] like it's going down hard
we're gonna watch her I've never cared
about story so much it's like you guys
just Jews all being petty yeah everyone
it's like I'm watching like a bunch of
girls insecure girls first part of it
that's some good lighting though to try
to cry pretty
I feel like she can't I feel like she
might have Bo Tigers she can't even like
squint we think we can all saw that this
is not so Jeffrey's loving this [ __ ]
loving this evening it was Jeffrey's
fans that dug up all that [ __ ] probably
will always happen after the documentary
series so like I said I only saw the
first one but I feel like there was
something in there that made people want
to go back and look [ __ ] up on people
but this is what Jeffrey tweeted he's
like imagine trying to bully me but you
actually end your own career instead oh
because he's been she's been losing
subscribers she's been losing money
because people would just call each
other out it's so weird when people put
out this insult that's directly it's
targeted toward someone they'd only say
it is it legal it's so weird
yeah why wouldn't it be they're not
making any claims it's not deaf amazing
no but I'm just saying like god it's
it's so like you know back in our
generation when people and rappers call
each other out it was not like each
other there's that actually put their
money where their mouth is but they also
just straight-up say like this guy's a
[ __ ] you know they don't go oh there's
a couple of [ __ ] in the world and I
don't give a [ __ ] about the beauty gurus
I think the [ __ ] people who are
looking for the dirt are the biggest
losers ever dude [ __ ] biggest losers
ever a burden
everybody's said or done something
exactly like everybody so it's like
everybody's done it it's like okay let's
just like not let's just be like alright
let's let's learn for me and like do
some other [ __ ] am i weird that I want
racist friends yes wow I just don't like
this like perception that everybody has
to be perfect and that's not the case
everybody you follow you idolize are all
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] some people are
just better at hiding it than others and
it's all about time and context yes like
a hundred years ago some stuff would've
been okay 100 years from now that [ __ ]
we're saying now a lot of it is not
gonna be okay it's like you just live
with the times and the fact that
everything was recorded and like put out
on the internet it's like and then
people will judge and dictate something
that's like 30 years ago it's like you
weren't able to do this 100 years ago
whatever you
like doesn't come back to hunting cuz
it's not recorded everything was
recorded out so it's like how are we
held accountable for stuff that we've
grown from or you're not the same person
you were five years ago even like a year
ago
you know like nobody is I'm not why are
we held accountable - I mean - dumb [ __ ]
because we were stupid but people change
political parties religions like yeah
everything changes every 10 years your
mind like completely changes into
someone else the personality everything
even your physical body chips so every
cell in your body yeah you're a whole
new person that'd be so funny like a
doctor is still yelling at a person
after they lost weight about being fat
yeah you do change your [ __ ] habits
how 70 I lost like 70 pounds because I
no no no no take your [ __ ] I need a
jog you know yeah I'm 120 pounds now oh
no you need to go run some more [ __ ]
stupid
you
you